regardez il ya un message je crois dans
les grades elle
c'était dur de poser une question que je
n'avais jamais posé
tous les quarts d'heure
vraiment
tu as une intelligence émotionnelle et
humaines hors norme d'où ça vient
[Rires]
votre super amis leïla bekhti est ce que
c'est une vraie question
ouais c'est une vraie question n'empêche
pas ce qu'en tout cas là je me du coup
je cherche la réponse
à l effort un bagne la débrouillez vous
avec ça aurait dû me dire ouais tu vas
nommé
d'où ça vient franchement déjà je ne
sais même pas
je pense comme elle je pense l'empathie
c'est pas forcément de l'intelligence
jeu par quelqu'un de l'uimm par exemple
très cultivé etc mais
l'empathie convaincante essaye souvent
que te mettre à la place des gens peut
être